حقيبه صغيره لمده طويله هكذا يبدو حزم
الامتعه للسجن اتهم ادهم بالقاء حجاره
خلال احتجاجات هبت ايار العام الماضي وقضت
محكمه اسرائيليه بسجنه 10 سنوات
حجر
القرار يغادر ادهم الى مرحله ستغير مسار
حياته
[تصفيق]
عندما تخلي السجن انتظره بعض الاصدقاء
والداعمين وحتى اخر لحظه ظلت والدته تنتظر
ان يتبدل الكابوس كما تقول
عمري راحت
وافرح حتى لو طلع خلاص يعني عشر سنين من
عمره هذول اغلى شيء انا بحياتي مش هونين
بين المساندين وقفت والده محمد وقد عاشت
هذه اللحظات قبل مده قصيره عندما صدر
الحكم على ابنها بالسجن سبع سنوات عقب
انتزاع اعتراف منه بما لم يقم بفعله قالوا
له انه امك ماتت اعترف عشان تطلع تحضر
الجنازه ولد عمره 18 سنه
اقدم اسرائيلي على دهس مجموعه من الشبان
الفلسطينيين في مدينه عكا فقبل بالحجاره
كان ادهم حينها في الموقع قريبا من بيته
ومنذ اذن لم يرن نور
كان وقع الاحكام صادما على عشرات الشبان
ممن ينتظرون احكامهم بتهم مماثله لا سيما
ان المحكمه اصدرت اخيرا حكما بالسجن لبدعه
اشهر على اسرائيليين اودين بالاعتداء على
شاب عربي في الاحداث ذاتها لكن هنا يكمن
الفرق بين هويه المعتدي والمعتدى عليه
وبين السجان
والحالم بالحريه
لا تغفل اجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه هو
جسمها من تكرار مواجهات ايار التي شملت
داخل الفلسطيني ولا يستبعد الفلسطينيون ان
يكون الهدف من وراء هذه الاحكام تخويف
الشبان والانتقام منهم بل فضه حاله من
الردع استعدادا لاي مواجهه مقبله
نجوان سمري الجزيره من امام سجن الجلمه
جنوب شرقي حيفا